hose pipe bands are to be introduced in
hampshire and the isle of wight from
friday next week southern water the
region's water company says the decision
was necessary to protect local rivers
which have become severely depleted by
the extended dry weather a hosepipe ban
has already come into force on the isle
of man the met office has said that the
period between january and june this
year was the driest in england since
1976 so let's have a look at the
rainfall in the isle of man on the isle
of man uh
28.9 millimeters of rainfall was
recorded compared to an average of 62.9
million
millimeters excuse me
for the same time uh year before that's
approximately 50 percent less than usual
now let's have a look at hampshire and
the isle of wight the isle of wight in
hampshire actual rainfall recorded this
year was 36.9 millimeters compared to
the long-term average of just shy of 53
millimeters and river flows are 25 lower
than they should be for july this is
equivalent to losing more than 25
million bathtubs of water according to
southern water they also say the area is
experiencing one of the driest years on
record for the past
131 years katarina vitozi reports
we've had water warnings
and now official restrictions
the hosepipe ban across the isle of
wight
and hampshire will affect millions of
customers
southern water says it's because below
average rainfall has hit water supplies
risking precious habitats and wildlife
that depend on the rivers
here on the isle of man where a ban came
in force today it's the shrinking
reservoir they're worried about
we've had a bit of a double jeopardy
situation where
there's very little water coming into
the reservoir now and the demand has
gone up by about 20 percent so what
happens is that the reservoir started to
drop quite steeply and it's now
approaching 65
in in the unlikely event that it doesn't
rain again until october by by the
middle of september we would we would
start to be in a serious situation
officials here estimate that the
hosepipe ban could help reduce consumer
demand by somewhere in between five and
ten percent and that restrictions will
stay in place until they can guarantee
water supply of course what would help
end restrictions earlier is if there is
some significant rainfall but remember
we're only halfway through summer and
typically august is one of our driest
months
on this island water supply is finite
some people have already turned to
storing rainwater
we've only got a limited amount and when
it does rain not all of it obviously
finds its way into the reservoirs so we
have to be very careful with our water
but having one of these is ideal for the
garden we do have to preserve it for us
because if we're going to have a mild
winter
then it's going to affect us
a lot we know human-made climate change
is affecting weather patterns making
extreme weather more likely their impact
more intense today land dried out by
record high temperatures fueled yet more
fires new climate modeling showed last
week's heatwave was statistically almost
impossible without global warming we
found that the 2022 event the
temperatures associated with the 2022
event
it's at least four degrees celsius
higher uh and that has been made for
degree celsius uh more due to climate
change and the the return the frequency
with which such events uh could happen
in the current climate is at least ten
times more likely as compared to a world
without climate change
water companies say there is no direct
risk to customer drinking supply but as
more hosepipe bans begin it's clear
restrictions now may help avoid
shortages later
caterina totsi sky news on the isle of
man